[Music]
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are officially married and no one
partied harder than their famous
families it's a beautiful thing
after the couple said i do at a ceremony
in portofino italy court and trav
ushered guests to the reception where
they were treated to their pick of the
finest italian foods and desserts
including fresh cannoli and pasta
stations which court says kylie showed
off
[Music]
kylie also shared the personalized table
cards and the stunning view from the
venue
[Music]
during the celebration courtney and
travis did their first dance the
performer legendary italian tenor andrea
bocelli who sang a rendition of can't
help falling in love
[Music]
up next a wardrobe change court swapped
her short white corset dress into a
black version of the gown both by dolce
and gabbana and then it was time for
some serious dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and kris jenner yeah the momager's
got some pretty sweet moves
[Music]
at one point during the reception
travis's daughter alabama went live
giving a glimpse of her dad removing
court's garter
and we can't think of a more romantic
moment than this kravis holding each
other tightly swaying to etta james at
last completely surrounded by their
loved ones
[Music]
the fun-filled reception comes after the
couple exchanged vows at the altar at
villa olivetta with all six of their
children by their sides we're just you
know living our best lives and
yeah
a source tells e.t that courtney and
travis couldn't be happier adding the
whole weekend has been amazing and their
italy wedding is everything they ever
wanted their friends and family are also
thrilled for them and can see how in
love they are
[Music]
you